michael thomas at can't guard mike is
part of that saints team that has won
six in a row including the win over the
Bucs yesterday joining us here in the
Rich Eisen show how are you Michael I'm
doing great thank you for for joining
what has come over this team over the
last six weeks that you I guess you
didn't have working in the first two
we're starting to develop identity guys
have started to get confident you know a
young team we know that so we can use AG
as excuse we're trying to win every game
we have on the schedule so you know guys
are starting to get confidence weekend
week out and we're also starting to play
together starting to close and so I I
feel like everyone starting to realize
if we did do our job no matter if it
just doing one simple thing or doing a
lot of things over a period of or the
course of the game we'll come out with a
victory and it won't be a close one so
there's obviously a fine line between
swag and stepping over it was real
chippy yesterday what was going on in
that field yesterday Michael with the
bum yeah I think we just went against
like a team you know once we I got up on
them we had they had some frustrated
guys you know our defense is not the
same defense they faced last year
they're constantly improving weekend and
we got nothing like there they're
holding their own there they're playing
this consistently and people are gonna
start to get frustrated and people don't
like facing that on Sunday well in terms
of the this team okay I'll give you the
sense of things with with the national
media that took a look at the Saints
this year and it's just the defense last
year as you all know wasn't as you point
out the same as it looks like right now
so a lot of folks kind of mark the
Saints down on that front and then the
offense Brandon cooks being sent away to
New England a lot of folks thought that
maybe just maybe they were without a
number one wide receiver what what did
you think of when you were here in that
sort of conversation about Brandon cooks
being sent away Michael
um ultimately control without control
trusted people around me trusted people
the tools that have been put around me
from the coaches that I have Ron Curtis
coach CJ and Ronald curry and
coach paid and then I knew what to have
another guys at my corner and just
having them in the receiving room for
all of us we're gonna be beneficial so
no matter who loves and who came and who
joined we're gonna be good for because
those guys are gonna coach Esther but
develop and do our job on Sunday well I
mean you could also look at that trade
meaning of voter confidence in you
correct Michael right oh yeah call it
what you want to call it you know I just
like to contribute that value to this
organization and win game and I was
wrong when you went in I like to win I
came from Ohio State where we pretty
much won every game I didn't really look
I saw like on inside like them but a
victory and seeing smiles on guy's face
it's because sometimes you know a lot of
people fighting come up in that same
environment where they're used to
winning so it might take some time to
get used to it so I'm just I'm happy to
just be on this streak and be playing
with these guys and see some of their
faces and starting to see guys
developing seeing guys getting
confidence and I'm more about team as
well okay so now I don't mean to correct
you isn't it the Ohio State Michael
right yeah sound like you left out be
right there right yeah I I know Michael
there's no doubt about that but your
quarterbacks at Purdue guy your
quarterbacks a Big Ten guy as well yeah
I get to so you know what is it like
catching passes from Drew Brees being
around him knowing what he has done and
knowing I guess the pressure of what he
expects of you Michael walk me through
that process what that is like he's
everything you could think of a football
player when you think of the greats you
think of a guy that handles his business
both on and off the field from
preparation watching film you know all
the things you hear he's that he's that
guy he keeps you honest he knows what he
wants he's he's a competitor
it's great having a guy like him the
benefit of having a guy like him behind
center just a blessing that being this
opportunity that's why they'll take it
for granted to have a quarterback like
him and I just want to always make my
make my player always if I don't make it
I want to ask how can I make it the next
time because just having a guy like that
you know he's gonna be ready and you
just want to be accountable and do your
job for a guy like that it's just
everything I don't want to sound cliche
or just sound like you know he's perfect
but he pretty much is perfect everything
the quarterback well he definitely knows
where you should be in a route that's
for darn sure he knows that so I know
that that that's got to have some sort
of pressure cuz look you know I've
interviewed a lot of people who have
played with first-ballot Hall of Famers
certainly when they have only a few
years of window of opportunity left as
we all assume would you never know how
long he's going to play and there's a
certain pressure like you can't let that
guy down you can't go back to the
sideline knowing that a window of
opportunity's closing even tighter when
a play slips away you know I've had
those confident people Ray Lewis for
instance nobody wanted to go back and
look at him if they didn't do their job
on defense with him of course everyone
here and starting with him they hold you
to a high standard you know and I just
wanted to step in and value like I keep
saying and also be at the right place at
the right time when drew puts the ball
in there and never put this team in a
bad position Bali's put them in a
position to win a game and you know it's
fun playing with those guys on Sunday
sales leave so have we just begun to
scratch the surface and what Alvin
Kamara can do in your estimation Michael
oh for sure yeah I mean with our defense
by how they're playing you know and I
look like [ __ ] we have on offense it's
kind of like everyone I feel like all
all the guys that touch the ball on
offense their big play guys and they
have opportunity taking the distance and
you know Alvin Kamara just a real
talented guy and he impressed this week
in and week out I feel like he's he has
a lot more he could show and I'm excited
to play with a guy like that also so
how many people are asking you for
tickets when you come out here in a
couple of weeks when it could be it
could be two eight and two teams facing
off against each other with the Rams
Michael you know families first so as
many as much as my family I'll be there
I haven't really made count yet but if I
took an estimate probably about 25
Billie's okay dice now he's coming
coming back home by the Rams it's gonna
be exciting how come you didn't stay
here to play your football here why'd
you go to the state of Ohio to play your
football in collegiate um just you know
my uncle went to USC I kind of wanted to
create a name for myself every time I
felt like I was kind of in the shadow
and kind of like being on the west coast
I kind of want to do something different
but still play big-time football and
still be able to chase my dreams in
eventually do the same things I could
have did at the West Coast schools that
I was looking at so you were like Ohio
State had all the tools okay so you
wanted to make a name for yourself
instead of being you know T Shawn's
living under my uncle yeah just look
around that Bothell shadow all the time
okay
so does that mean your uncle doesn't get
tickets when he comes in a couple of
weeks right now that's my family I'm
just saying as far as it's created a
name for myself okay
and how has he helped you doing become
what you become
Michael Keyshawn Johnson um he's helped
me tremendously
he's completely honest in the data I
could go to when if I have a question
about anything and he's a guy I played
for a very long time so he has a lot of
experience so a guy would experience you
find that they they could help you more
than someone that doesn't have as much
experience so he's a great guy to have
my corner it gives me tons of advice but
he also tells me what I need to do
better and things I need to work on all
right last one for T Michael Thomas what
is what is your coach talking about is
the word Super Bowl being mentioned by
Sean Payton who clearly knows what it
takes to win one Sean Payton the egos he
definitely knows what it takes to win
one and but he's a guy that I'd like to
he doesn't underestimate anyone and she
lets us know that we can a week out and
we're going to get
we're gonna get the best you know these
every team that we face from here on now
we're gonna get their best game you know
everyone's gonna try to knock us off the
top and try to knock us off you know
King the hill so he keeps us on it and
yell he tried to go week in and week out
but at the end the day I hope I'm
thinking like something's cool all right
act can't guard Mike on Twitter let's
get the followers up right Michael yes
Hey look thanks for coming on the show I
appreciate you you join and we'll chat
again soon okay thank you you got of
course that's Michael Thomas okay
there's gold bucks right there for more
Rich Eisen show tuned - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Rich
Eisen show app